pues sí hoy arrancó el juicio de los
atentados de barcelona y andrés pérez un
juicio algo peculiar ya que recordemos
todos los autores directos de este doble
atentado fueron abatidos por la policía
el conductor responsable del atropello
masivo aquí en las ramblas de barcelona
el 17 de agosto de 2017 fue matado por
la policía cuatro días después y la
misma noche del atentado en los cinco
terroristas que también atropella gana
gente aquí es cerca de barcelona en
cambrils fueron abatidos
esa misma noche así pues en los tres
acusados que se sientan en el banquillo
desde esta mañana de la audiencia
nacional no son considerados
responsables directos de este doble
atentado y por ese motivo la fiscalía no
les acusa de asesinato algo que hubiera
querido la acusación popular y las
familias de las 16 víctimas mortales
ellis le preguntó quiénes son estos tres
presuntos acusados y que dijeron en el
comienzo del juicio
pues dos de estos tres acusados son
presuntamente miembros activos de esta
célula yihadista está mohamed
sembla él es el que más arriesga 41 años
de cárcel salió herido de la explosión
de la casa de alcanar donde los
terroristas preparaban el plan inicial
que era construir bombas para se
explotan algún monumento esta mañana el
presunto terrorista dijo que se
arrepiente que no está a favor de los
atentados y dice también que no era el
mismo en los vídeos que se proyectaban
en el juicio donde se le ve claramente
preparar estos explosivos el segundo se
llama él y su carga arriesga 36 años de
que hacer sobre todo por haber alquilado
la furgoneta que sirvió para el
atropello masivo aquí en las ramblas de
barcelona dijo que no sabía para qué
querían alquilar esta furgoneta y el
tercer acusado él está acusado de
colaborar con la célula yihadista
prestando vehículos él dijo también que
no sabía cuál era el propósito
este vehículo y de estos jóvenes el
juicio tiene que durar hasta el 16 de
diciembre y más de 400 expertos se
estaban declarando en la audiencia
nacional así es el is gracias por
información vamos a estar muy pendientes
a cómo se desarrolla este juicio